you gave Eminem one of his best club
records he's ever
I feel like smack that's a song that
like still gets played no it is at like
[ __ ] 11 p.m at whatever Club you guys
but see and it was interesting because
every record I ever put out I actually
produced except smack that really who
Did That Eminem produced that record I
missed Eminem when he was isn't that
crazy
crazy I missed I missed the Eminem
producer era when he was producing a lot
of his own [ __ ] yeah I know his Beats
weren't the craziest but his Beats were
like very distinct you heard it right
and you knew his sound it knew it right
right and I'm like oh that's dope M's at
least got his own skin remember he was
doing uh he was he produced Renegade
right he produced uh the cross for Nas
on God's son yeah he produced a lot of
dope [ __ ] but I don't know I think he
got I don't know if he got away from it
or maybe I'm tripping or he stopped
sounding like that but I feel like the
last album had a lot of his own [ __ ]
that I was like oh that's what I was
missing from him he always had them it's
always some small little sounds I think
dude it was something minute that you
just it was I think it was like it felt
like Eminem I was like oh this Eminem
beat I could tell yeah 100 m m has some
heat rocks that day